what's going on guys this is Rob in as
I'm still doing my research for Jason
Todd I thought it'd be fun to make a
video looking at a character from the
media and comparing them to the comic
books asking the question which version
is better the media version or the comic
book version and in this video we're
going to be focusing on Tony Stark Iron
Man
so the Iron Man in the comics has a very
large portfolio of publications and it's
52 you run a Marvel Comics so far but
for the most part only a handful of
these stories are actually considered
classics in Marvel Comics proper stories
like armor Wars dealing with Justin
Hammer stealing the plans of the stark
armored demon and a bottle dealing with
Starks alcoholism and extremists which
is the basis for most of the content
behind the Iron Man films easily fit the
bill of being classics but the crown
jewel of iron man's publication history
comes with Civil War and the reason for
this is because iron man was not very
interesting in the comics leading up to
Civil War demon in a bottle was the only
real story that made Iron Man feel
almost human but since it was a
miniseries that feeling went away almost
immediately sure he was a founding
member of the Avengers but when compared
to characters like Captain America Thor
or even ant-man Hank Pym stark seems
almost as emotionless as his armor now
all this changed with civil war the
reason why is because during this series
stark went from being a moderately
decent character to a point of major
discussion and contrition among comic
book fans given his stance in support of
superhuman Registration and count book
fans even went as far as to renounce his
motives and simply just consider him an
all-out and Marvel Comics
recognizing this opinion kept this
opinion going among comic book
characters in Marvel Comics who would go
forward
hating Tony Stark entirely in addition
to this Tony Stark's reaction to the
death of Captain America gave us a depth
of character hitherto unseen in his
entire publication of history in Marvel
Comics now a Tony Stark and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe lacks in character
history is made up for with the
character itself Tony Stark from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is uncouth
unconcerned and downright belligerent
but it's hysterical in doing it the
entire time whether he's making candid
sexual references to Pepper Potts on
American cheeseburger
and the other that tonight that's not
what you think I want you to call for
press conference now getting drunk at a
party or else dealing with his robots
Tony Stark in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is lightyears ahead of it's
coming back outer part in terms of
charisma comedy and downright interest
in addition his character is also given
death when we see him dealing with the
ramifications of the extremis program
when we see him dealing with the
ramifications of all the stark armor and
looking to the future with regards to
the age of Ultron storyline where Tony
Stark is revealed to have been the one
that created Ultron and the fallout of
creating an immense being with such
incredible power who would go on to
become a villain against the Avengers so
the question becomes who comes out on
top of this debate is a comic book Tony
Stark or is it media Tony Stark
of course it's the media version of Tony
Stark why wouldn't it be this character
is hands-down the best version of Tony
Stark that has been presented to us to
date and it's done in such a way that
this actually revitalized interest in
Tony Stark and led model to create
superior Iron Man a comic book version
of Tony Stark which is almost identical
to the version that we see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with that being said
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it and let me know down in the comments
section which version of Iron Man you
prefer the most I will catch you guys
later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly
[Music]